le passage de la vague n'a laissé que
des ruines
difficile d'imaginer ici l'un des ports
les plus animés de la côte nord-est du
japon
avant le tsunami une centaine de bateaux
mouillaient en permanence dans ce bassin
le marché fourmillaient d'activités 2000
tonnes de poissons sortait chaque année
des usines de tarot
ce village de pêcheurs situé 650 km au
nord de tokyo a été l'un des plus
meurtrie par le tsunami
yoshinori shimizu est l'un des 700
pêcheurs de tarot depuis le raz-de-marée
il n'avait pas revu le port une épreuve
trop douloureuse
il accepte pour la première fois de
retourner avec nous à l'emplacement de
son plus gros bateau
c'était la mort qui leur tenait
au bout de cet amas le 4 tonnes avec
lequel il pêchait le saumon depuis 23
ans la vague l'a emporté comme une
simple bout et
je n'avais pas encore vu les dégâts
mais ça me décourage
je me sens si triste mon coeur à mal
aucune trace de son embarcation réduite
en miettes ou emportés au large
quelques centaines de mètres plus loin
yu xin harry aperçoit une carcasse de
navires
je le connais celui-là il était amarré
juste que tu es du mien
bon pour la casse
la flotte de tarot a été décimée
1960 embarcations que comptait le
village le tsunami en a épargné et 40
yoshi marier ses proches ont perdu leurs
huit bateaux
je suis content de ne pas avoir le mien
ça m'aurait rendu très triste
voire un bateau mort c'est le pire pour
un pêcheur je ne vais pas le chercher
c'est trop dur à vivre
trois mois après la catastrophe
yoshinori est seul ce jour là sur le
port le lieu est désert le marché aux
poissons est la seule structure encore
debout
je travaillais de ce côté là
l'armée
le tsunami était énorme monstrueux
notamment personne n'aurait pu imaginer
ça moi je n'en avais jamais vécu mais
même les anciens disent qu'il a été
beaucoup plus loin que ce qu'il pensait
[Musique]
en 1933 un précédent tsunami avait déjà
frappé tarot mais la vague avait alors
été trois fois moins haute que cette
fois ci
depuis le village était réputé avoir
construit la meilleure protection anti
tsunami du monde la grande muraille de
chine du japon comme l'a surnommé
fièrement le gouvernement
la vague n'a fait qu'une bouchée de ses
digues prétendument protectrice
sur cette vidéo amateur on aperçoit même
quelques inconscients partie admirer le
tsunami depuis la digue
ils seront emportés
hu
en quelques minutes 1600 maison un tiers
de ce village de pêcheurs
est anéanti
[Applaudissements]
pour héberger les habitants qui ont tout
perdu la mairie de tarot a réquisitionné
un gymnase
[Musique]
un espace divisé par des cloisons en
carton
afin de reconstruire un semblant
d'intimité
après plusieurs mois de vie en commun le
centre ressemble à une ville en
miniature ou même la police patrouille
trois fois par jour l'armée distribue à
manger au menu riz soupe aux légumes et
jus de fruits dans la file de
distribution nous découvrons madame chi
minh et sa fille à eric
le grand père de la famille était
pêcheur lui aussi à 74 ans ils partaient
encore ramasser les filets tous les
matins chez les shimizu d'aussi loin
qu'il se souvienne le pacifique les a
toujours nourri
avant la catastrophe les hommes féchain
et les femmes et cahiers le poisson
autour de la table familiale
la question n'est pas réglée faut-il
reprendre la mer ou pas
moi je veux retourner pêcher j'ai un
permis j'ai envie de l'utiliser
mais pour mon fils je ne suis pas sûr il
doute
je ne sais pas encore ce que je vais
faire ça va coûter très cher de tout
reconstruire
avec une famille à charge je pense que
je vais avoir besoin d'un travail à côté
en tout cas au début les reconstruire
peut donner
il songe à devenir chauffeur routier
même s'il n'en a pas envie s'éloigner de
la mer rassurerait les enfants désormais
à hiré l'adolescente veut devenir
fonctionnaire un métier sans risque est
loin de l'océan dit elle
avec ma famille je n'ai pas peur mais si
je m'approche de l'eau je panique je
pense à tout ce qui pourrait arriver
dans quelques semaines la famille
shimizu devrait quitter le gymnase
pour s'installer juste en face
la ou des préfabriqués sont en cours de
construction
chaque famille pourra y loger deux ans
sans payer de loyer c'est ce qui a été
décidé pour eux
[Applaudissements]
sauf pour ceux qui reprennent en main
leur destin et la mer le plus vite
possible c'est l'objectif du grand-père
shimizu
nous l'accompagnons auprès de
l'association de pêche de la commune se
renseigner sur le plan de relance
a dit monsieur d'année ici c'était la
compta kevin rudd
là le service des ventes de la
mairie de tarot est aujourd'hui en
charge de la reconstruction des quais
mais c'est aux pêcheurs de se
débrouiller pour reformer la flotte
l'association a emprunté un million et
demi d'euros pour acheter 150 bateaux
qu'ils devront se partager entre les
familles du village
des bateaux d'une tonne 8 comme celui là
on en a commandé 50 et on a aussi pris
20 barque de hinton comme celle là sinon
utilisez
le 160 bateaux les deux tiers étaient
assurés
l'argent que vont toucher les
propriétaires ne sera pas suffisant pour
acheter un bateau neuf mais au moins ça
va les aider
pour les 200 qui n'étaient pas assurés
il n'y a rien de bon
selon leurs estimations relancer
l'industrie aquacole à tharaux coûtera
près de 6 millions d'euros une somme que
l'association ne peut espérer lever les
responsables comptent sur un éventuel
plan dette du gouvernement pour
l'ensemble du secteur de la pêche
la principale industrie à tharaux ce
sont les produits de la mer si on ne
peut pas pêcher c'est la mort assurée du
village
sénonais j'aime la merde
c'était à moi je ne pourrais rien faire
d'autre que pêcher jusqu'à maman
malgré leur détermination
il leur faudra des mois pour reprendre
le large
le long du littoral le tsunami a détruit
dix neuf mille bateaux et les usines de
construction n'arrive pas à suivre
avec 33 mille kilomètres de côtes
protégées par des digues des exercices
d'évacuation annuel des milliers de
panneaux d'avertissement
le pays qui compte le plus de
tremblements de terre et de tsunamis au
monde se croyait près
pourtant les digues se sont révélées
aussi insignifiante qu'une ligne maginot
même celle de taral 10 mètres de haut
plus de deux kilomètres de loin n'auront
pas pu empêcher les maisons les toits
bleus et blancs sur cette photo aérienne
prise avant la catastrophe
d'être rayée de la carte par le tsunami
pourquoi c'est la question à laquelle
veut répondre l'équipe du professeur
sakai ses ingénieurs parcours les zones
dévastées depuis trois mois de part et
d'autre de la digue de tarot les maisons
laisser place à des terrains value
ding qui est encore debout là bas est la
première construite en béton dans les
années 30 sont pour moi ni la tradition
veut que les gens se sentaient protéger
ils ont commencé à construire au-delà de
ces digues là où nous en trouvons
maintenant
donc dans les années 50 il a fallu
construire une deuxième digue mais la
même histoire s'est répétée et donc il a
fallu construire une troisième
protection un brise lames à l'entrée de
la baie
de ce côté là on sera plus près
grâce à l'analyse de l'impact de la
vague le long du rivage nippon ces
spécialistes des tsunamis espère tirer
des leçons pour la reconstruction
je mesure la hauteur du tsunami afin de
calculer sa puissance
[Musique]
avec une vague jusqu'à 38 mètres de haut
c'est le tsunami le plus violent qu'ait
connue le pays
ici passer la route principale la digue
à stopper la vague l'eau s'est mis à
tourbillonner sacré ce trou
cet impressionnant
très vite connaîtrez dans la baie mais
entre la première et la deuxième ligue
il y à quelques centaines de mètres qui
se sont transformés en bassin
le niveau de l'eau est monté peu à peu
avant de passer cette dernière digue ce
qui a donné aux habitants peut-être une
minute ou trente secondes pour s'enfuir
ça semble peu mais c'est ce qui a fait
la différence entre survivre ou se noyer
contre les occupants
mais les digues de tarot ont aussi eu un
effet pervers
persuadé que cette muraille les
protégerait certains habitants ne
respectait plus les consignes de
sécurité et ne s'enfuient et plus
lorsque l' alerte était donné bonjour je
viens de l'université d'iwate et
comment avez vous vécu le tremblement de
terre
c'est un mât perdu des amis monté sur la
digue après le séisme pour regarder la
vague arriver
les avoirs des mots qu
on a souvent des tremblements de terre
du coup c'est vrai on les prend à la
légère
moi quand il y avait une alerte au
tsunami en général je ne confierais pas
hype
comment mieux protéger la population
avant de présenter dans quelques jours
un projet anti tsunami aux autorités le
professeur veut encore se rendre dans
une autre ville à 80 km de tarot à coude
j il y a eu autant de dégâts qu'ailleurs
mais un chiffre a retenu l'attention de
l'ingénieur ici seulement six décès à
déplorer
là devant l'ot a tout détruit
[Musique]
pour analyser les photos satellites et
les images de l'arrivée de la vague il a
rendez vous à la mairie de kuji
cette zone a été touchée est celle là
aussi
ici lorsque l' alerte a sonné les
villageois se sont précipités vers les
hauteurs
et les pêcheurs ont ont foncé vers leur
bateau
affronter la vague de face comme vont le
faire les deux chalutiers à l'image
c'est la seule solution pour sauver une
embarcation en cas de tsunami
malgré la puissance des flots ils s'en
sortiront indemnes
tous les habitants de kuji sans
exception étaient parfaitement rodé aux
exercices d'évacuation
pour diminuer encore plus les risques
l'idéal ça serait que les gens
n'habitent pas près de la mer et des
ménages vers les collines
mais les japonais sont très attachés à
leur terre comme moi ici comme la
population était bien informé
ça a limité le nombre de victimes quand
les digues n'ont pas tenu
sauf tôt
la leçon que je tire de ce qui est
arrivé c'est qu'il faut sans cesse
préparer les gens à avoir les bons
réflexes
et construire des structures pour les
protéger
ceux qui disent que les digues sont
inutiles c'est exaspérant et dangereux
sans digue les dommages seraient bien
pires sans sensibilisation les victimes
seraient bien plus nombreuses
il n'y aura jamais de mur assez haut
pour arrêter tous lectionnaire
kuji avec sa politique de
sensibilisation au risque pourrait
devenir le modèle de la reconstruction
japonaise
comment reconstruire réparer embarqué
cette cote montagneuse entrecoupée de
cris qu est l une des principales
régions aquacole du pays
à eux seuls ces centaines de petits
ports aujourd'hui en miettes fournissait
un million et demi de tonnes de poissons
coquillages des algues soit le double de
la production française
à 50 km au sud de tarot le porte domo et
où les pêcheurs organise déjà la
réparation des bateaux qui n'ont pas été
déchiqueté par le tsunami
à gauche le pêcheur takashi yamashita
coordonne le redémarrage de l'activité
ici était cultivé une variété d'algue
essentiel à la cuisine nippone les
halles de ouakam et
celles d'homo et était réputé les
meilleurs du pays
les 1600 villageois vivaient de cette
pêche
avec la destruction des plants et la
disparition de la quasi totalité de la
flotte la communauté est à genoux
c'est le plus gros bateau opxt des
bateaux on en a que 5 ou 6 2 réparable
et celui ci est le plus important
il n'est pas trop abîmer il devrait
pouvoir naviguer à nouveau rien au
canada
après un mois et demi de chômage
technique et aucune aide des autorités
takashi yamashita a décidé que les
pêcheurs devaient se prendre en main
seul seven casino notre priorité c'est
de restaurer les bateaux et de
recommencer à pêcher même si le port
n'est pas encore réparées
est ce que les autorités vont nous aider
est-ce que nous allons devoir tout
financé
rasé mais dès qu'on ne sait pas on n'a
reçu aucune information et benoît
le convoi emportera deux bateaux sur un
chantier naval à plusieurs heures de
route sans savoir encore si l'atelier
fonctionne depuis le tsunami
le village domo et est située sur un
escarpement la vague n'a pas atteint les
maisons posées en hauteur seul le port
dans la crique a été engloutie
[Musique]
une fois le chargement des bateaux
terminée takashi nous emmène sur le quai
où les pêcheurs air désoeuvrés
tous sont inquiets sur l'avenir de leur
métier
350 kilomètres plus au sud la centrale
nucléaire de fukushima a relâché dans le
pacifique plus de onze mille tonnes
d'eau contaminée par des particules
radioactives
selon les autorités les creux du marin
de cette région ne seront pas affectés
les pêcheurs n'en croit rien
son signe donné
cette affaire le gouvernement nous
informe trop tard
comme on est éloigné on va être moins
affectée si tout va bien on peut espérer
atteindre le même niveau de récolte dans
les deux ou trois années qui viennent
mais autour de fukushima à cause de la
catastrophe nucléaire c'est sûr ça va
leur prendre au moins dix ans avant de
pouvoir à nouveau partir en mer
il donne des nouvelles rassurantes à la
télévision auprès de pas nous effrayer
mais nous on sait qu'on va être affecté
ici on pêche des poissons qui viennent
de fukushima si les bons circule le
courant circule
les pêcheurs de moules sont d'autant
plus vulnérables que selon les études
scientifiques les ald qu'il cultive
capte la radioactivité 30 fois plus que
le poisson
afin de re motiver les hommes
l'association de pêcheurs organise une
réunion cet après-midi
c'est la première depuis le tsunami une
centaine d'hommes s'est déplacé
l'ambiance est tendue
nous faisons face à une situation
inédite
et nous devons trouver une manière pour
nous en sortir ensemble
[Musique]
pas un mot pendant la rencontre des
fuites radioactives
nous interrogeons les responsables après
le départ des hommes
leur mot d'ordre pas de panique tant que
les officiels à tokyo dise que tout va
bien
oui on est inquiet à propos des fuites
de fukushima
[Musique]
si cela s'aggrave nous les pêcheurs on
ne pourra plus faire notre métier et
nourrir les nôtres
la nature souffrent et nous dépendons
d'elle
c'est une crise grave pour notre
profession
si après tous ces efforts nous ne
pouvons rien vendre nous serons des
dindons de la farce la moitié des
pêcheurs présents cet après-midi pensent
comme moi mais il n'y a rien à faire
il faut sortir en mer récolté récolté
espérer que tout cela stas
la réunion débouche sur un résultat
concret
le lendemain les marins ont réuni les
quelques barques en état de naviguer
leur mission vérifier si le tsunami qui
a détruit leur culture a épargné les
algues sauvage
regarde là bas la zone la plus sombre
il espère récolter des semences pour
relancer l'aquaculture d'avion
aucune
à l'aide du moule sous-marine takashi
scrute le fond de l'océan
après avoir parcouru plusieurs crises
vide
enfin la bonne nouvelle
des algues c'est bon tout la zone noire
la
cdu wakamé
environ 10 tonnes d'algues les entoure
de quoi monter un business plan en
quelques mots loto
si on empêche une tonne de ouakam et ça
fait 400 kg de produits finis
et on pourrait empocher 2000 euros mois
au monde paye de haut niveau comme les
algues existent et ont bien plus grande
quantité que ce que j'imaginais
je pense que dans deux ou trois semaines
on va pouvoir les récolter et reprendre
les ventes
et
il
oubliée la violence du tsunami et la
peur des contaminations
[Musique]
en quelques minutes la maire a offert à
ses hommes le cadeau dont il avait le
plus besoin
l'espoir